what's shaking man hey how's it going
rick
it's going real good what can i do for
you brother good um
well i actually like read your book not
too long ago
uh i've been following for a long time
too um
i have a question about like trying to
get over
anger towards women just in general
um like how do i just
not care anymore
give me the background story so i
understand where the uh caring is coming
from
um well
just female nature in general
like my mom did it to my dad when they
got divorced
i see it like in the workplace
just even like you know trying to spin
plates with other girls and stuff they
all have this narrative
and it just makes me so mad like i
almost just don't even want to deal with
it
why do you get mad why does it anger you
um i just feel like they don't
maybe intentionally try to screw over
men but
they always do at one point or another
well for one
sex to advance its cause it's going to
come at the expense of the other sex
you read that part of my book right yeah
so i mean like it's it's
it's only 200 pages i mean i could have
made it 800 pages but i only made it 200
pages i just wanted to distill down the
main points so
if there's a piece of advice i can give
you if you have the book is read it two
or three times
um that being said how old are you i'm
24.
and like heartbroken is that what
brought you the red pill or was it
something else
um i guess you could say that but i mean
that was just a long time ago
like so what happened she bounced on you
she
banged your best friend like what
happened um
she started doing meth and heroin behind
my back
and it just went into a downworld spiral
you know she started stealing from me
the whole 10 yards
so okay so i mean like here's a question
that i'm going to come at you with now
is why do you care
like like these are red flags like this
this would easily be like
she she did meth and heroin could easily
be red flag number 21 from my book
yeah i mean i mean i could have had 80
red flags in there i could have probably
800 if i wanted to keep going but i
wanted to keep it down in the main shed
i mean
not everybody's going to have an
experience with the check that does meth
and heroin but i kind of expect guys if
they're reading my stuff and watching my
stuff
to understand if she's doing these kind
of drugs
it's kind of a [ __ ] deal breaker like
you're on your own oh yeah
yeah i didn't even know about like this
whole red belt thing like
five six years ago but right but i mean
like
how old was this chick uh she was 17
and i was like 19 at the time okay and
you're still thinking about that you're
24 now right
um i i mean i usually don't think about
it anymore i've
i've moved on what is it about women
that annoys you and frustrates you like
when you see things happen at work
um they expect you
to hold their hand through the whole
thing
like does that make sense like yeah well
well it's a double standard because i
mean
they've been going on about how they're
so strong and independent but at the
same time they want you to hold their
hand and walk and walk them through like
they want you to lead them
so exactly whenever there's a conflict
between
what's said and what the behavior is
watch the behavior watch what women
respond to so if they respond to a
strong
masculine alpha man with a strong frame
that likes
you know that can lead women and women
are interested in following
then do that never mind the hey i want
to be equal i want to make as much money
as a man i don't like this dollar 74
you know in every dollar like sorry i
don't like the 74
cents on every dollar a dollar sorry a
man makes
you get the point though right it's like
all of that blah blah [ __ ] blah
about politics gender issues
i'm gonna just ignore it just lead you
don't have to worry about
about conflicts between what's said and
what's done because you're always gonna
believe the behavior so
once you understand female nature and
their behavior then
you respond to the behavior right you're
not going to respond to the words
okay as much that makes sense because if
there's a conflict the behavior trumps
the words right
right exactly that's all it is dude like
you just have to keep like
like going through it and looking at
opportunities to
see the world in a new light
because once you kind of like read my
book and you watch a bunch of my videos
there's a lot of [ __ ] that i've talked
about over the years i mean i've got
over 100 episodes now on this playlist
but a lot of stuff i've talked over the
years with a lot of different [ __ ]
guys and it's like okay
that didn't work let's stop doing that
and let's do this
right yeah definitely and
not get mad because you have to do this
because that's where guys get mad it's
like
i'm doing this i've always done this i
was always told to do this
this is how i'm going to do things and i
don't want to stop doing this
and doing that too bad buddy you have to
do that
so can i ask what you do in a certain
situation
go alright so i was at the bar
saturday night right and i was with my
stepbrother
and his wife uh
so my stepbrother he starts puking all
over the place he got way too drunk
and his wife starts talking to this
other guy
i'm trying to get him out of there
because the bar is closing it's super
late
right in front of me she's getting this
other guy's number
i take her back home both of them and i
get a phone call from him like
two hours later like hey she's gone like
she's over at some dude's house like
this is
exactly why i just have so much anger
towards women
like this literally just happened the
other night so like what could i have
done
to make that different well you could
have done a few things i mean
you could have called her out on it she
probably wouldn't care
but i mean the question that i'm asking
myself is why do you surround yourself
with
low caliber people
meth addicts guys that [ __ ] go out
partying and
barfing their brains out in front of
their girlfriend i mean you can't blame
his wife for talking to another guy
that's not a
[ __ ] you know past that on the floor
drunk
yeah i guess right it's in her nature
to want to have like the best guy in her
life
and passed out drunk on the floor is
[ __ ] loser
i'm sorry you know he's your brother and
all that but that's but that's losing oh
yeah no i get it
so if the other guy's like stand up dude
and he's
funny and he's had a few drinks he's not
passing on the floor
i mean should she have done that because
she's married probably not
but that's what [ __ ] chicks do
yeah right so you just have to look at
and be like
look man you don't want her bouncing on
you and banging some other guy then
don't be a passed out drunk on the floor
like a loser
for starters because that's what you
can't control you can't control her
i mean you could start talking to this
guy about red pill concepts and be like
hey man you should read this book over
here it's a really it's a really good
book by the way it's on amazon print
kindle oh i have audible
i'm doing my sales pitch but i mean like
you get the point though right
yeah yeah right i mean you know
women are going to be women it's you
know it's why
when a hot girl walks out wearing very
little clothing with big boobs and a
round butt i'm gonna look at it
i don't care who's with me doesn't
matter to me
i'm a guy that's what i do right
women husbands passed out drunk on the
floor i bet you there's other stuff
going on going on in that relationship
that you don't know about that's
probably not the first time
i'm sure that she's raised concern about
his drinking habits perhaps i don't know
but you can't get mad at her she's a hoe
all
all women are garden tools given the
right circumstances
right the only time they're not is if
they get up in the morning and they look
at you and they're like
this guy's the best i can do i'm real
happy with that
i'm gonna make sure that i come home
tonight and i cook dinner i'm gonna wear
that little black dress and i'm gonna do
everything that he likes in the bedroom
because he's the best i can do
that's what i need to find well
how are you gonna find that if you're
hanging out with meth heads and guys
that
get pissed drunk and fall on the floor i
used to have this friend that i used to
hang out with in my 20s and my 30s way
too long i let the guy hang around
way too long exactly like that loud
obnoxious he was a bad drunk he was an
angry drunk he was a physical drunk
and exactly like that exactly like that
you can't level up in life if you let
people like that into your life
i'm not saying you know be a jerk to him
or never see him again i mean you know
you got family events
maybe do those but is there something
that you could have possibly done
that would have been a better use of
your time on saturday night than hanging
out with
your passed out drunk brother
step brother right yes okay whatever so
it's
arm's length but you get the point right
yeah
definitely i mean you could have done
like you could have found something
better to do with your time
you could have watched the documentary
on a business leader you could have read
my book for the second time you could
have gone through some evo psych books
you know you could have
i don't know taken a course online i
don't know but
was it a good use of your time to hang
out with the meth head no was it a good
time
like you've got to start making some
better choices in your life like wearing
a just do it on your shirt ain't gonna
make [ __ ] happen you actually have to do
[ __ ]
i get it yeah you know what i'm saying
like michael jordan
[ __ ] did it oh it definitely did
you want a good book to read you know
follow up to kind of like you know get
your mindset
into like you know that whole athletic
leadership sort of thing
read uh relentless by tim s grover
okay okay the guy worked with all the
top athletes
and he tells all the [ __ ] stories
about how fastidious these guys were
about being successful at their craft
and you'll get an idea of the kind of
choices you have to make if you want to
be successful and get better results out
of life
yes definitely that's where you got to
start for yourself you know what i'm
saying
yeah i definitely need to do that for
sure okay man appreciate it and
do me solid if you did read the book
through go to amazon and leave me a nice
review there written review it helps out
okay ready all right bro thanks all
right thank you
you